une nouvelle aventure pour thomas d'erik
satie montant de 21 ans va tenter de
traverser la france en voleur et oui
vous avez bien entendu
ce sportif de l'extrême est parti la
semaine dernière depuis à lille pour
rejoindre le sud avec son ami justin
andres 22 ans originaire des vosges
bonjour à tous les deux alors comment
vous est venue cette idée bonjour locale
alors cette idée est devenu un peu
communément suite op vide s'est dit que
c'était le bon moment pour y aller par
notre pays en france et à l'euro l'eur
c'est une pratique on aime tous les deux
donc on s'est dit que ça pouvait nous
réunir pour un voyage
alors est ce que vous vous présenter les
grandes lignes vraiment de votre
aventure
comment ça va se passer alors on a
commencé donc depuis là on a récupéré
nos voleurs et ensuite on a quelques
grandes étapes vers trans des religions
ensuite leur valence et ensuite le but
il arriver au moins à marseille et après
ce sera que du plus on veut vraiment
arriver dans le sud est après l'espagne
et comment ça se passe et ça sera des
plus tôt des petites routes
cca plutôt des départementales ou des
pistes cyclables on évite macro tout à
ne pas rouler mais majoritairement en
effet la piste cyclable c'est plus c'est
plus sécuritaire pour nous alors est-ce
que tout est définie thomas d'eric ou
est-ce que vous laisser un petit peu de
place au hasard on n'est pas à remettre
en question notre itinéraire on peut
très bien changer de trajectoire au fil
du voyage
c'est avant tout l'idée lui décernant
deux de profiter on n'a pas vraiment
d'objectif sportif on n'a pas de km h
deux prévues tous les jours c'est
vraiment en plus où est le plus
important pour nous c'est de faire des
rencontres
pendant le voyage est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter vos rollers est ce que ce
sont des rollers classique où ce sont
des rollers professionnels alors on a
des rollers oxelo aimef 900 c des
rollers classique disons assez de ce
sont des bons rouleurs mai entrée de
gamme accessible
c'est pas des rollers à 400 ou 500 euros
professionnels donc finalement s'est
déroulé des rouleurs contre n'importe
quel des quatre noms donc c'est vraiment
ce qu'on fait c'est vraiment accessible
à n'importe qui faire un sac à dos aussi
grâce à cox est donc un petit sac chacun
ça fait quarante litres à 2 à 48 c'est
très peu pour traverser un pays s'est
séparé en fait c'est ça sera aussi un
défi le voyage mais ce n'est pas trop
compliqué justement d'avoir un sac à dos
avec des rollers non ça va parce qu'il
est assez petit assez compact et c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt agréable de la voir
sur le dos au final épatant dérogeant et
comment vous faites pour dormir
on a la tente dans le sac avec les
duvets donc dans deux sacs 20 litres
faire entrer la tente les duvets à la
trousse de toilette et le reste de
l'équipement plus des pièces de rechange
pour les rollers c'est vraiment un défi
c est triste dans le sac c'est assez
amusant mais on a tout sur nous on est
capable d'être en autonomie donc voilà
on peut poser la tente au bord de la
route il faut mais la majorité du temps
mais s'il devait sonner du coup chez les
gens pour qui nous accueillent dans leur
jardin et on dort chez des gens très
accueillants avec nous il donne à manger
à boire
on fait aussi de belles rencontres
justement vous êtes partis il y a une
semaine pour l'instant tout va bien les
habitants ouvrent leurs portes
assez facilement tous les soirs alors
tous les soirs on a dormi dans des
jardins que tous les soirs on a
rencontré des gens parfois ils nous ont
invités à dîner
là par exemple ce soir on passe une
deuxième nuit chez l'habitant
chez les ch'tis on se trouve à guise
dans l'aisne et on va dîner avec lui ce
soir donc on fait toujours de belles
rencontres
on n'est pas à l'abri de avoir une
rencontre ils ont les pieds
ce sera vraiment ce sera pas grand chose
par rapport à toutes les bonnes choses
qui ne sont arrivés à côté est ce que ce
n'est pas trop dangereux de faire ce
périple en roller en sachant que vous
êtes sur la route quasiment tout le
temps si c'est dans l'est il ya deux
jours dans une descente en fait j'ai
fait une mauvaise chute et mon genou a
cogné sur sur le béton dont j'ai fait un
petit détour aux urgences
pour betty avait rien cassé donc tout va
bien je continue à baisser si c'est sûr
qu'il ya des risques
il ya des risques étant dès qu'on est
sur le bord de la route ou le temps et
que bah on peut tomber on peut faire mal
avec les automobilistes pour l'instant
ça se passe bien ça se passe bien mais
chaque route c'est un petit peu une
découverte disons à on a souvent peur de
tomber sur des automobilistes qui font
pas attention donc le danger il est là
c'est le plus grand danger de ce voyage
avec moi on a vraiment des fois des gens
nous frôlons n'a vraiment peur de d'une
mauvaise rencontre avec une voiture et a
même chuté sur une départementale ça
peut ne pas pardonner
donc ça c'est vraiment l'aspect
compliqué du voyage alors thomas d'eric
vous êtes un habitué des traversées
extrêmes on peut le dire vous avez par
exemple traverser le désert de sel en
bolivie à l'été dernier le salar d'uyuni
est ce que cette aventure en bolivie
vous sert aujourd'hui disons que c'est
des aventures qui m'ont vraiment donné
confiance en moi
et du coup voyager en france aujourd'hui
ça me paraît moins dangereux moins
compliqué moins stressant que si je
l'avais fait avant mais traversée dans
les déserts de sel mais chaque voyage
est différent et en fait on avait peur
qu'il a à chaque fois sont très
différentes par exemple quand justin
allait tomber ni j'avais une
problématique que j'avais pas dans le
désert c'est à dire je m'inquiétais pour
quelqu'un d'autre que moi et chaque
voyage est différent je peux c'est sûr
que ça m'aide aujourd'hui mais j'avais
parlons pas de bottes pas à gérer dans
le désert dernière question qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter de la chance
de la chance avec les voitures
merci à vous deux et à bientôt sur tv 68
pour le débrief de votre aventure